oh non on a remis avec la touche
[Applaudissements]
exécution le roi de la triche quelle
belle cueillette nous filme et plus
motivé que jamais
pourquoi cette année on va voter pour
élire le président des élèves voter
maintenant
plein d'idées pour améliorer l'école le
candidat idéal c'est lui
favoriser mais
attendez
c'est la catastrophe nucléaire vous avez
frappé à la bonne porte je déclare
Ducobu président des élèves
ils ont tous le fond
[Applaudissements]
c'est la zizanie
tu devrais essayer ça fait un bien fou
je vais vous apprendre le Béaba de la
triche mais j'ai jamais tricher de ma
vie monsieur ah bah il serait peut-être
temps de vous y mettre
la guerre est déclarée je vais
contre-attaquer alors de la révolte
sonner
[Musique]
organiser la rébellion à son potage pour
lutter contre les méthodes du commun
d'ici là je veux que vous contactiez les
bons élèves discret sur
Président je vais vous faire la dictée
super c'est clair
[Musique]
le 13 juillet au cinéma